welcome back to CBS mornings and we turn
now to the story about the future of a
three-year-old girl rescued after a
military raid in Afghanistan she's now
at the center of Court battles here in
the U.S two families say that they want
to care for this little girl this child
known as baby L there's an Afghan couple
now in the U.S who say that they are the
child's rightful family and they accuse
an American Marine and his wife who have
adopted the girl of unlawfully taking
custody of her only on CBS Morning
senior investigative correspondent
Catherine Herridge spoke to the American
couple just two days before a Virginia
Court said they couldn't speak to
anybody placing a gag order on the
Family's prohibiting them from talking
about the case so this is their first TV
interview and for now their only
conversation about it Catherine good
morning good morning this story has an
incredible number of layers but at the
heart of it there are two families who
truly believe they are doing the right
thing when it comes to this child's
future
chose how strong you are with training
wheels and some encouragement she looks
like any other three-year-old learning
to ride a bike but this child's story is
anything but ordinary it begins on the
battlefield in Afghanistan in September
2019 when a counter-terrorism team
zeroed in on this remote compound babyl
was severely injured in the raid and her
parents were killed she was roughly two
months old we met resistance almost
immediately this former Army Ranger who
will call David for security reasons was
on the mission which combined U.S and
Afghan forces he spoke exclusively with
CBS news on the condition we Shield his
identity and change his voice in this
firefight you hear the sound of a baby
crying yeah it's almost unnatural
responses that you're going to hear that
and uh
an unclassified military report reviewed
by CBS News found the child was likely
the orphan daughter of an Al-Qaeda
foreign fighter who entered Afghanistan
from a neighboring country the baby's
right here in this corner David says
partner Afghan forces then suggested
throwing the baby in a nearby River they
wanted me to throw the baby into the
river because I believe that she was a
terrorist six additional Army Rangers
also on the mission backed up at David's
account telling CBS News some Afghan
forces suggested drowning or abandoning
the baby to die as a soldier and as a
new father what was going through your
head
it was definitely not an option the Army
Rangers made a car seat from scraps and
medical equipment a bandage wrapped
around her head on route to a U.S
military hospital is one of her first
known pictures so you have a lot of
severely injured Rangers
but they're going around that site and
they're trying to Fashion a car seat
must have been a lot of dads on that
operation
at a military base babiel was treated
for fractures to her leg and skull and
second-degree burns on her face and neck
I know exactly where I was Joshua Mast a
marine lawyer was deployed to
Afghanistan at the time he wasn't on the
raid but says he heard about the child
from his boss he's like what the heck
are we going to do with this baby what
baby sir it's like Oh The Operators
pulled a child off an Al-Qaeda objective
was really bad when Mass learned about
the baby he called his wife Stephanie
who was in the U.S raising the couple's
Sons the moment when we ver we heard
about her for the first time it wasn't a
difficult decision to make it was just
there was an innocent child caught in an
unfortunate situation and we wanted to
see if there's anything we could do to
help and we were able to this photo
shared with the Mass is from a nurse's
station I would say that's one of my
favorite photos of her because
again like behind her there's a you know
combat trauma center right and like a
real military hospital where service
members are coming in from the war in
Afghanistan and you got this little girl
that they've taken care of and I don't
know it is it's everything good about
America in that photo as the child was
treated in a military Hospital the mass
began the process of officially adopting
baby l in the U.S meanwhile the Afghan
government and the International Red
Cross search for babyl's biological
family in Afghanistan
according to court documents the baby
was eventually given to an Afghan couple
the then Afghan government determined
the husband to be the baby's first
cousin the couple asked to remain
anonymous due to safety concerns for
themselves and their families in
Afghanistan as the Taliban took control
of Afghanistan in 2021 the Afghan couple
agreed to bring the baby to the United
States in a federal lawsuit the Afghan
couple claims the mass encouraged them
to bring the baby to the U.S solely for
medical care but never told them they
had already adopted the baby were you
clear with the couple about your
adoption yes because we're expanding
substantively that we have to treat her
like our other children in a way that to
communicate the clearest we could that
hey we're responsible for under U.S law
but on the word adoption sure did you
use the word adoption I don't think I
use the word adoption
we were trying to explain again in a way
that they would understand because they
don't have a concept of adoption in
Afghanistan over a three-month period
CBS News reached out to the Afghan
couple for an interview their lawyers
declined most recently citing the court
gag order
Cabo fell the Afghan couple and the baby
were evacuated by U.S forces first to
Ramstein Air Base in Germany where the
mass met them at a refugee camp babiel
was now about two years old when you
found her
did you immediately recognize her
no not at all I it was I was shocked she
didn't look like the child in the
hospital in the hospital she had big
brown eyes big smile and when I saw her
she had furrowed brow and she was kind
of scouted closed off and it wasn't
until I saw the scar on her leg because
she has a very distinct Scar and I was
like it's her it's really her
that's where the fight over this child
really begins tomorrow in part two we'll
show you the chaotic moment the child
was transferred to the mass the Afghan
couple says they did not know the mass
had officially adopted the baby in the
U.S and were blindsided when the mass
took custody plus the surprising DNA
evidence and why the U.S government is
taking such a strong position in this
case it seems like Catherine you could
say a lot would be lost in transition
and with culture and and with how they
do things there do you think the couple
really didn't know that they were giving
the baby up for adoption on the question
of adoption the simple explanation in
Afghanistan is that it's much more of a
guardianship system I mean this is
probably one of the most complex
investigations I've ever taken on and
it's got this incredible emotional
overlay and then you've got the defense
department the justice department the
state department the Taliban all
weighing in about the future of not only
this child but both of these families
yeah two households saying we're in a
position to love this child we want this
child in two countries saying you know
this is the best place for her yeah yeah
wow I'm really looking forward to part
two Catherine thank you